most people just think like you have one
arm it's impossible to play video games
another favorable kickoff go in the way
of ashley
will he be able to get a fourth will he
be able to find a lead he's got the flip
reset he's going to get it over lewis
i went to one of ashley's streams and
there was actually playing with one arm
and a chin and i'm like
ashley is way better than me with two
hands
hitboxes giving scrub problems actually
flicking another one by world class
mechanics he's he's absolutely the top
tier mechanically and you wouldn't know
that he's doing it all with one hand oh
ashley oh ashley oh ashley that's
amazing if you're born with a disability
you can still make it you can do
anything even if there's something
holding you back you can still do it
trust me you can just do anything
hey folks before we get into ashley's
incredible story i just want to let you
know that this video is brought to you
by geico look being an amazing rocket
league prodigy isn't easy but you know
what is switching to geico 15 minutes
can save you 15 or more on car insurance
so if you want more info check out the
link in the description below all right
back to the video
rocket league is one of the hardest
games to play at a high level whether
you're bounce dribbling musty flicking
power sliding or doing a wave dash
kickoff it's a game that relies on
precise inputs muscle memory and split
second decision making which makes it
all the more incredible that one of the
most exciting prodigies the game has
ever seen please with just one arm i
went to one of ashley's streams and
there was actually playing with one arm
and a chin and i'm like
ashley is way better than me with two
hands
nice
there is a long history of disabled
athletes finding ways to excel at their
games and in the realm of competition
esports is a fantastic equalizer no
matter your situation we all compete in
the same arena take growly legs for
example despite being born with
arthrogryposis and scoliosis he's
managed to dominate able-bodied players
at a high level i did always get that
look you know when i had when someone
had to play me you know they looked at
me and they're like you know this is a
free win is this a buy
and you know
it kind of gave me that drive that to
beat them because i was like no you know
i'm here to knock you out
oh wow didn't get the flash kick he
tried to go forward anti-air with that
crouching yeah you can't answer
or as another example there's sightless
combat who fought his way to the top of
killer instincts leaderboard despite
being completely blind regardless of
their situations disabled competitors
have proven that in esports anything is
possible but nothing is easy and ashley
is no exception
world-class mechanics he's absolutely
the top tier mechanically and you
wouldn't know that he's doing it all
with one hand holding the controller
like a violinist holds up holds a violin
and pushing these
i mean rocky controls are quite
difficult to begin with you have to do a
lot with your thumb if you play default
controls you have to jump boost power
slide and flick click on and off ball
cam with your thumb like he does all
that with his chin he just pushes the
buttons with his chin born with one arm
ashley grew up playing soccer a pastime
that naturally translated into video
games when he learned how to play fifa
with his feet but by the time he was
nine he stumbled on a game that would
change his life forever
[Applause]
[Music]
in 2015 rocket league launched as a
free-to-play ps4 game and ashley was
hooked instantly
but he just couldn't continue using his
feet to play the game i don't really
know why but i started having like this
like spasm in my feet where the muscle
just wouldn't
i don't just really hurt then so i
thought
i can't i have to change now because i
can't be playing and then this just
happens
but and then i think i tried a few
one-armed controllers out like i don't
know about the maid
so you can use one arm but i didn't
really like them
because it didn't really optimize how
i wanted to play but instead of giving
up ashley only grew more determined and
then one day out of the blue he
discovered a better way to play
remember one day i picked up and tried
playing with my chin
and
it just worked i i started to like get
better and progress slowly obviously
it takes time to put this in perspective
imagine playing your favorite
competitive game one-handed imagine
putting your hands on the controller or
the mouse and keyboard and then taking
one off and still trying to compete at a
high level what actually had set his
mind to do seemed impossible
you need to do everything yourself every
movement of the car every jump every
turn every um you know time you you use
boost to accelerate it's a button press
or a button hold so it's completely
mechanical and it's completely free form
but once he figured out his winning
formula ashley devoted himself to
getting better every day he'd come home
from school and practice every nuanced
mechanic there was it didn't matter that
he only had one hand he was determined
to get better
gonna be a tough game but we can win
nice good kick off you get the boost
i like spike then okay
we'll take our timer's cork
nice ashley had been laying relatively
low until fellow englishman and pro
player apparently jack tweeted about the
young up and comer shortly after that
rocket league's biggest content creator
musty featured him in an interview so
you have four buttons to click with your
chin and like the four like buttons you
need that are very important to the game
yeah i i'm just curious like how did
like that muscle memory even like start
working i just don't understand like how
how that's even like possible man i
guess like like you it's a judas
practice if you keep on doing it and
doing it and doing it you'll eventually
get to know it right but if the
community hadn't taken notice of him by
then ashley was about to make sure that
they would never forget his name by
taking down the former world champion
scrub killa
now we'll have a flick chance gets it by
scrub inching within ashley will take it
[Music]
right by scrub i'm not sure he's going
to get back to that one yep perfectly
placed
hitboxes giving scrub problems ashley
flicking another one by
on ashley dodging the air demo attempt
we'll take this the distance scrub
killer will be down by three less than a
minute left ashley making a name for
himself here on the mainstream ashley
five thousand dollars richer and he's he
was able to beat a legend in one scrub
killer the two-time titan the season
seven world champ will fall
now while ashley did beat a former world
champion he did it in a 1v1 match see
competitive rocket league is played in a
3v3 format at the highest level and
since ashley was too young to play pro
he had to settle for dominating the 1v1
circuit
most recently he was a runner-up in
dreamhack's european 1v1 boost cup
so smart from actually he could have
taken a shot off kickoff but he knew
that wasn't every chance in the world
that it would be going in getting the
triple reset oh yes he does barreling
down the field what are you indeed this
this is just ridiculous
it's run away from lewis p hasn't this
is the first time where we've really
seen him
properly properly struggling since
rosie's i want to say oh ashley oh
ashley oh ashley that's amazing
another favorable kick off going the way
of ashley
will he be able to get a fourth will he
be able to find the lead he's got the
flip three set he's gonna get it over
lewis p
four
not good enough to get himself that
sixth goal lead back in attack
off the wall he sat on the ceiling
looking for the delay must be oh my
goodness i've got whiplash from that
shot and so from unranked to bronze all
the way to supersonic legend and through
to the top 0.1 percent of players in the
world ashley has continued to climb
despite all odds
people need to know that everything's
anything's possible if you're born with
a disability you can still make it you
can do anything
even if there's something holding you
back you can still do it trust me you
can just do anything
it's all about time
i put in six hours a day grinding and
grinding until i got i'm still going to
do it grinding running until i get what
i want
along the way ashley has received a ton
of love and support from every corner of
the rocket league community i think the
coolest thing was seeing the positive
response
in twitch chat when we showcased ashley
on um
on the rlcs yes
the community is absolutely behind
ashley it was so cool but it's not just
his play that inspires me and inspires a
lot of people it's the way that he
handles himself and uh his humility and
is willing his willingness to learn and
uh to improve ashley made his name in
1v1 and while he doesn't have a team yet
he's finally 15 old enough to play in
the rlcs which means the future is still
wide open for rocket league's most
exciting prodigy
but the fact that ashley is is showing
already that he can compete against some
of the best he's taken down some of the
best in ones right
and translating that into threes just
takes a team behind you i really don't
think that that ashley's obstacles are
stopping him now he has found a path
and he is in a position to be a player
that will compete and hopefully in the
next like years a few years gopro
hopefully that's the end goal
to be at alan playing my league doing
wallop
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]
you